spit flying riding a skiing down the
mountains of flying down
it's close to the ground with a mini
glide no more than 10 meter square one
of the good thing of this activity it's
that you can go and write in some places
even the world freeride skiing champion
could not do
when the run is just finished you still
full of adrenaline you need time to
count down after all that strong and
that speed you know that's the best drug
you can have you know old regza this one
is good this is the Mount Aconcagua it
is the highest mountain in South America
and America's I climbed up to run 13
days we had some storms we had some snow
and everything like this and then to go
down has been five minutes geez run on
the agar was something like a bit less
than three minutes conditions were
perfect and we had a very very good
right down
I wish to everybody to be more in
contact with natural elements it's good
for the mind this is this is good for
the spirit